GILBERT STRONG: This is the
second video on second order
differential equations,
constant coefficients,
but now we have a
right hand side.
And the first one was free
harmonic motion with a zero,
but now I'm making this motion,
I'm pushing this motion,
but at a frequency omega.
This is my forcing term.
So I think I'm having a
forcing frequency, omega,
and remember that for this
one, for the no solution,
there was a natural
frequency omega n.
It's very important
are those close,
are those well separated?
That governs whether the
bridge that you're walking over
oscillates too much
and eventually falls.
Or in the extreme
case, are they equal?
If omega n is equal to omega
that's called resonance.
Let me put that word in.
Resonance.
When omega equals omega n.
And we're not going
to deal with today,
but you should know that
always the formula has an omega
minus omega n dividing by that.
So if that is 0, if
omega equals omega n
our formula has to change.
Today, this won't happen.
No.
So what's the formula?
What is yp?
I'm looking for a
particular solution.
That's a nice function and
also important in practice.
So I would like to hope that
the particular solution could
be some multiple of
that cosine omega t.
And in this problem
that's possible.
Because if I have a cosine, I've
got a cosine on the right hand
side, and if that cosine comes
here, it's on the left side,
and the second derivative of
the cosine is, again, a cosine,
I'm going to have a match
of cosine omega t terms.
And then I'll just choose
the right number capital Y.
I won't be able to
do that when there's
a first derivative in there,
because the first derivative
of cosine will bring in signs.
I'll have a mixture
of cosines and sines
and then I better
allow for that mixture.
But here I don't have to.
There's the forcing function.
Response, this is
the forced response.
I'd like to get used
to that word, response,
for the solution.
Here's the input, the
response is the output.
So let me just plug
that into the equation
and find capital Y.
So here I have m, second
derivative is going to be a Y,
and second derivative
will bring out a minus
omega squared times the cosine.
And here I have kY is Y times
the cosine equal the cosine.
I could have a constant
there, but the whole thing
would be no more interesting,
no more difficult than with a 1.
So what do I do?
The nice thing is here
I have all cosines,
so I'm just going to have
minus omega squared m and a k.
So it's k minus m omega squared.
Can I write it that way?
Times Y. I'm going to
cancel the cosines.
That's just a 1.
On the side is a 1.
I've canceled the
cosine, so I've kept kY.
I've kept the 1, and I've
kept a minus omega squared mY.
So that tells me Y right away.
It's just like plugging in
an exponential and canceling
exponentials all the way along.
Here, I'm canceling cosines
all the way because every term
was a cosine.
So I know Y. So I
know the answer.
So the final answer
is Y(t) is Yn.
Well, let me put Y
particular first plus Yn.
So I've just found Y particular.
Y particular is this
capital Y cosine omega t.
So it's cosine omega t times
Y and Y is 1 over this.
Here's goes Y. Down below I
have k minus m omega squared.
Right?
That's what we just found,
that particular solution.
The capital Y, the
multiplying constant,
was 1 over that constant.
And now comes the C1
cosine of omega nt
and the C2 sine of omega nt.
Remember, omega n is
different from omega.
Actually, this is
pretty nice here.
I could write that
another way so you
would see the important here.
So remember, what
is omega n squared?
Can I just remember that
omega n squared is k over m.
Right?
Yup.
k is the same as-- I'm going
to put that m up here--
k is the same as
m omega n squared.
m omega n squared
and here I'm subtracting
m omega squared.
You'll see the whole point of
resonance or near resonance
when the bridge is getting
forced buy a frequency close
to its resonant frequency.
This difference, omega
squared, the difference
between the two frequencies
squared is in the denominator
and will be small and
then the effect is large.
And if we get those too close,
the effect is too large.
So we'll see this cosine omega
t over this is, I would call,
the frequency response
is this factor.
1 over m omega n squared
minus omega squared.
That's the key
multiplier for when
the forcing term is a pure
frequency, that frequency
gets exploded.
And now, of course, what are
capital C1 and capital C2?
We find those from
the initial condition.
At t equals 0, we
put in t equals 0,
and that tells us
what C1 has to be.
And we put in t equals 0 again
to match the velocity Y prime
at 0, and that tells us C2.
Are you OK with that?
Just look at the beauty
of that solution.
This is null part.
This is the forced part,
the particular part,
the cosine divided
by that constant.
There's one more
equation, one more
forcing term I'd like often
and always and now to discuss.
And that is a delta
function, an impulse.
So I'm going to add
one more example.
my double prime plus ky
equal the delta function.
Delta function.
It's called an impulse.
So I'd like to solve
that equation also.
When the forcing term just
happens at one second,
at the initial second.
At t equals 0, the
delta function,
I'm hitting the spring.
So the spring is sitting or
the pendulum is sitting there.
Actually, let's set it at rest.
Here's my pendulum.
I'll try to draw a pendulum.
I don't know.
That's not much of a pendulum.
But it's good enough.
This equation says what
happens if I hit it
with a point source?
At t equals 0, I hit it but
I give it a finite velocity.
It doesn't move in
that instant second.
This is where delta
functions come in
so let me give you the
result of what happens
and then we'll see them again.
So what am I doing?
I want to solve this equation
when the forcing function is
a delta function.
So I'm going to call y
the impulse response.
It's the solution that comes
when the forcing function is
an impulse.
So y is the impulse response.
In fact, it's so
important, I'm going
to give it its own letter. g.
Now, can I turn that y into a g?
So that g is g of t is
the impulse response.
If I can solve that equation.
You might say, not so easy.
With a delta function, it's
not even a genuine function.
It's a little bit crazy.
It all happens in one second.
I'm sorry, in one instant.
Not over one second,
but one moment.
But I can solve it.
I can solve it for this reason.
I can think of it
as an impulse here
or I have an option,
another way which clearly I
can think of it as solving it
with no force mg double prime.
Same problem, same
solution is 0.
But I start from rest.
Nothing's happening.
y of 0 is 0.
And it starts from an initial
velocity, y prime of 0.
The impulse starts it
out like a golf ball.
Just go.
And there's a 1 over m there.
I'll discuss that another time.
What I want to see now is that
I have either this somewhat
mysterious equation or this
totally normal equation,
even a no equation starting
from y of 0 equals 0.
But with an initial
velocity that the impulse
gave to the system.
And I should be calling this g.
This is the g.
We'll see impulse
responses again,
but let's see it this time
by solving this equation.
So I plan to solve that
equation and actually we
solved it last time.
You remember the
solution to this one?
When it starts from
0, there's no cosine.
But when the initial velocity
is 1 over m, there is a sign.
So I'm going to just
write down the g of t,
which is just sine of omega nt.
And why is it the
natural frequency?
Because I'm solving the no.
I'm looking for a no solution.
But the previous video on
no solutions gets me this.
Only I have to divide by, get 1
over m as the initial velocity.
You'll see that that will
solve the no equation.
This is what happens to the
pendulum or the golf ball.
Well, pendulum much better.
Actually, golf ball
is poor example.
Sorry about that.
Golf balls don't
swing back and forth.
They tend to go.
I'm looking at pendulums,
springs going up and down.
So the spring starts out, has
an initial velocity of 1 over m
and then after that
nothing happens.
So that is the impulse response.
The response to an impulse.
And why do I like that?
First of all, its beautiful.
Simple answer.
Secondly, every
forcing function,
and the output
comes from this one.
We'll see that point.
So we've introduced forcing
functions, cos omega
t, where the particular solution
was a multiple of cos omega t.
And now, we've introduced
a forcing function delta,
the delta function where the
response is a sine function.
Thank you.